the purpose of my videos is to let
people know that like it doesn't matter
who you are it doesn't matter what age
you are like you could truly do whatever
you want to do if you put your mind to
it and I say that in every single one of
my videos every single one of my live
streams I just got all this attention
from smoking in the stores to like let
these kids know they can truly do
whatever they want to do in my videos
like halfway through I'll start letting
them know the truth like yo all we have
is the present moment my friends we
don't have the past we don't have the
future you guys could truly do this too
like I'm just like a skinny Asian kid
like doesn't matter what age you are you
can truly do whatever you want to do I
just want to let them know like we're
the only people that hold us back from
doing the [__] that we got to do you
feel me and now let them know too we got
to keep it pushing you feel me you woke
up today because your ass has a goddamn
[__] purpose and Mission you
feel me like real [__] I love the
positive M that's what I was really like
pleased about when I started like going
through all your stuff is to find that
message it's like I'm going to get your
attention with all this crazy
off-the-wall [__] but then once I have
it I'm going to fire you up and leave
you better than before you were when you
start watch